sie sind finanzminister und die größte
oder einer der größten diskussion in
diesem zusammenhang sind die steuern
natürlich da gab es forderungen aus
ihrer partei der parteivorsitzenden dass
man möglicherweise die steuern erhöhen
müsste insbesondere für vermögende
wie stehen sie dazu und gleichzeitig gab
es die diskussion dass man eigentlich
die steuern erleichtern müsste um die
konjunktur wieder anzukurbeln was ist
die position des finanzministers erst
mal da sind wir uns alle einig die
parteivorsitzende mit mir und dem
fraktionsvorsitzenden dass wir jetzt
erstmal die entscheidung zu treffen
haben die wird der jetzigen situation
etwas zu tun haben und dass wir dann
später entscheidungen treffen die dazu
beitragen dass die konjunktur wieder
anfährt dass arbeitsplätze gesichert
werden und dass wir uns auch gedanken
darüber machen wie die einkommen der
bürgerinnen und bürger gesichert werden
können auch für längere zeit auch das
spielt hier eine rolle will das nochmal
erinnerung rufen alle reden von den
helden des alltags die dafür sorgen dass
alles am laufen bleibt die auch viel
einsatz zeigen zum beispiel in den
krankenhäusern oder wenn es darum geht
lebensmittel zu verkaufen und das alles
tun
das muss ja dann nach der krise so sein
dass die auch mal mehr verdienen da sind
dann deren arbeitgeber die privaten und
öffentlichen gefördert das gefordert das
möglich zu machen
wir haben uns vorgenommen dass wir die
zusätzlichen schulden wieder
zurückführen ab 2023 in 20 jahren und
eins ist ganz klar wir werden diese
riesigen aufgaben die wir jetzt zu
schultern haben auch auf dauer nur mit
einem fairen und gerechten steuersystem
schultern können dass es schon immer die
meinung der spd
jetzt kommt es raus dass wir wirklich
recht hatten denn so starke reaktion wie
der deutsche staat jetzt zeigt zur
stabilisierung von wirtschaft und den
einkommen der bürger und bürger kann nur
ein staat mit fairen steuern überhaupt
leisten und deshalb bleibt es unsere
aufgabe dafür zu sorgen dass das meer in
richtung gerechtigkeit geht und nicht
mit steuersenkungen für spitzenverdiener
beantwortet
noch eine abschluss war mehr in richtung
gerechtigkeit das heißt dann ja doch am
ende aus ihrer sicht sozusagen höhere
steuern für vermögende
erst mal ist es eine alte forderung der
spd zu sagen entlastung unteren und
mittleren einkommensbereich und
diejenigen die ein paar hunderttausend
euro verdienen können vielleicht dafür
sorgen dass diese entlastung auch
finanziert werden können damit sind wir
auch in die letzte bundestagswahl
gegangen das haben wir auch versucht
jetzt bei den koalitionsverhandlungen
durchzusetzen klappte nicht weil wir da
unterschiedlicher meinung sind was wir
durchgesetzt haben ist die entlastung
von 90 prozent derjenigen die heute den
soli zahlen
indem wir den ab dem beginn des nächsten
jahres spätestens ab schaffen für alle
diese steuerzahlungen steuerzahler und
das hilft vor den allen dingen die wenig
verdienen oder ein mittleres einkommen
haben